soir
donc en cause
catherine laborde
ces décrets matin qu'une dame hier
catherine laborde et son niveau tremblay
catherine voulait absolument que tu sois
là ce soir là roux ici à des serviettes
ne t'inquiète pas c'est parce que on a
fracassé le plateau il ya un instant une
autre émission c'est toujours deux
salles deux ambiances avec moi mais je
voulais absolument que tu sois là parce
que pour moi tu étais le plus beaux
moments que j'ai vécu dans cette
émission
voilà je voulais te le dire je voulais
que tu sois là ce soir et je veux savoir
comment tu vas machine écoute quand on
me dit ce que tu viens de me dire là on
est très très très bien c'est une rose
de maladies avec des hauts et des bas et
beaucoup de sensations du monde
extérieur
je me semble que je connais un petit peu
chaque personne ici c'est une dame en
fous je sais que c'est faux mais mais je
sens leur présence intime et ça fait
c'est ça me fait beaucoup de bien
c'est une belle et bonne chose et s'il
n'y avait pas eu la maladie j'aurais
jamais eu cette sorte de facultés isère
les autres peut-être qu tu ressens plus
les gens oui c'est ça et je les ressens
davantage dans leurs commentaires pour
pas être ridicule non mais bien dans
leur dans leur bienveillance dans l'eure
dans leur douceur dans leur gentillesse
oui j'ai eu mon cher eric puisque vous
vous êtes un littéraire n'est ce pas
j'ai vu un interview l'autre jour de
louis ferdinand céline
ce grand écrivain du début du 20e siècle
et qui avait une réputation épouvantable
et sans doute mérité mais qui a tout
d'un coup dans l'interview il a dit
qu'il faisait usage surtout de la
douceur et je me suis dit zut alors
la douceur c'est franchement c'est une
des plus belles choses de la vie la
douceur dans le monde où on est avec ce
rythme obligatoire de la maladie des
pépins et des choses pas drôle il peut y
avoir la douceur alors catherine vous
étiez venu nous voir le 19 octobre
depuis vous vous battez contre la
maladie
quels souvenirs vous avez de cette venue
sur le plateau parce que vous nous avez
confié beaucoup de choses
j'étais très ému et très et je n'avais
pas peur parce que j'étais heureuse et
j'attends d'être malade mais je suis
extrêmement poreuse et avec vous cyril
dans vos bras et bien je n'avais plus
peur de rien et ça c'était un sentiment
extrêmement joyeux bas il faut rester
tout le temps dans les bras long
vraiment été magnifique mois catherine
secousse avait quelque chose à dire à
catherine est ce que vous l'avez une
question à lui poser
parce que catherine j'aimerais après tu
lance un message à tous les gens qui
nous regardent
parce que je crois que c'est important
de lancer un message soit il ya ton
livre tremblay qui est magnifique on en
avait parlé quand tu étais venu karim
peut-être moi j'ai pas envie de lui
poser des questions et j'ai mis de lui
dire ce qu'elle me ferrosan palace et
sari bref qu'elle me fait ressentir je
l'avais dit le soir que ton était venu
nous rendre visite et je le redis ce
soir quand elle présentait la météo je
trouvais qu'elle dégageait beaucoup de
douceur de bienveillance de que de
gentillesse au sens noble du terme de
qui est effectivement après elle est
venue nous parler de sa maladie je lé
encore plus aimer parce que j'avais le
sentiment qu'elle était dans un combat
difficile et et que ce qu'elle nous
renvoie comme comme douceur comme
bienveillance comme amour on a envie de
lui donner de catherine on a envie de
lui rendre
en fait c'est qu'après il faut il faut
considérer que la personnalité que vous
avez que qui se dégage de vous génère
des zones d'eau positive naturellement
autour de vous c'est c'est vous dire on
ne fait pas exprès d'être gentil avec
vous mais on n'est pas gentil à vous
parce que vous êtes malade on est gentil
avec vous parce que j'ai envie de dire
on peut pas faire autrement à sa
catherine laborde tout cas moi c'est ce
que je ressens
parce qu'encore une fois d'une
personnalité se dégage des choses qui
est de vous je ressens d' de la
gentillesse donc de la douceur de la
bienveillance et donc automatiquement ça
nous rend plus sage et plus gentil aussi
dans votre livre tremblay vous ne
prononcez jamais le nom de votre maladie
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez plus de
facilité en parler à a prononcé son
sommeil côté je me suis tellement
appliqué à enterrer ce nom un défaut de
pouvoir enterrer la maladie j'ai du mal
avant d'entrer sur le plateau là je me
suis remémoré comment ça s'appelle déjà
la maladie j'ai je n'oublie j'ai pas
l'appeler le nom et la maladie et là on
sait aussi c'est pour s'assurer que je
voudrais insister je suis très contente
d'être ici parce que il ya beaucoup de
gens qui nous regardent et je voulais
dire à tous ceux qui sont victimes de
cette maladie ou qui sont les aidants
c'est à dire les les proches qui
prennent en charge la maladie
voilà je voulais leur dire que même
s'ils sont seuls ils ne sont pas isolés
ou même s'ils sont isolés ils ne sont
pas seuls c'est une maladie certes
difficile à vivre mais il faut il faut
compter sur les autres
il faut essayer aussi ça c'est plus
compliqué ne pas trop attendre des
autres qu'il devienne ce que je parle
man finhan pas du tout comprends tout à
fait ce que vous dites vous dit tout est
faux vous pouvez penser que vous on peut
quand on est malade quand on atteint de
cette maladie tête attendons beaucoup
des autres peut-être été trop compter
sur les autres oui mais trop parce que
c'est trop lourd pour eux on les appelle
les étangs que ça ne soit rien moi en
plus c'est ce qui qui veille à ce que
provoque pas visible vous le
culpabiliser parfois vous dit peut-être
que je demande trop aux et là c'est donc
assez sûr c'est vrai c'est sûr il paraît
d'ailleurs que quand y'a un couple comme
ça de malades aidant aidé ce sont les
aidants qui disparaissent les premiers
tellement la vie est difficile pour eux
est sans doute comme vous le dites avec
beaucoup de culpabilité inutile mais
voilà elle je voulais insister et dire
aux gens qui ne regardent que voilà on
n'est pas tout seul on n'est pas isolés
et qu'il faut faire un faut prêter
attention aux aidants j'oserais dire
merci à 82
[Applaudissements]